it's time for scene and unseen where we
reveal the stories behind the headlines
and for that return to Fox News
contributor Raymond Arroyo all right
Raymond there has been a lot of talk
about Mike Pence and Chris Christie
entering the presidential sweeps but
what's happening on the left I think is
a little more fascinating Maybe
Laura look there's a clearly growing
disenchantment with Joe Biden as the
Democratic candidate and it's coming
from the left RFK Jr's already jumped
into the race he did a big Twitter
interview today well now Cornell West is
throwing his scarf into the presidential
ring
can these Bleak times
I have decided to run for truth and
Justice which takes the form of running
for president of the United States as a
candidate for the People's Party neither
political party wants to tell the truth
about Wall Street about Ukraine about
the Pentagon about big Tech do we have
what it takes we shall see
we shall see indeed Laura look this is a
threat to the president as an
African-American leader here is
challenging him in a third party run and
Biden needs black voters to win
re-election as Congressman Donalds was
telling you a moment ago Black America
has been taken for granted and nobody
else is talking about these issues both
RFK Jr and Cornell West are going to
push issues that Biden have been has
been trying to cover up for years
yeah Biden's never going to debate them
and the media will do their best to
ignore them but I've got to say Cornell
West
he ticked off all those issues and I'm
thinking okay surveillance State
Pentagon Ukraine like I agree with him
on probably all those issues like
remember he used to come on the radio
show where the two the show a while ago
I know what he's been on this show
and RFK junior is going down to the
border for three days something Biden
certainly doesn't want to talk about
we'll see if the Democratic Party begins
to look Anew at these issues and if they
make a difference now if the president
had a big campaign event this weekend
Laura he was campaigning to get a ball
into a cup without falling over Biden
and his brother Jim hit the greens the
sitting president seems a little less
busy than the guy who can no longer run
for president who you might remember do
we have speed
let's go first job Baskin Robbins in
Honolulu Hawaii but secretly I was
convinced I'd be an NBA player I had no
hops my favorite job was being president
of the United States my favorite job
perk uh Air Force One favorite way to
relax after a long day of work a cold
martini
sitting outside if it's nice chatting
with my wife
now Laura do we actually believe that he
considers that relaxing I'm not going to
get into it but he and Michelle have
produced the Netflix show with Obama
exploring the lives of American workers
this would be like King Charles hosting
a documentary on welfare recipients you
know Obama and workers what's next Chuck
Norris on the lives of drag queens I
mean these two things have nothing in
common
I think we're seeing way too much of all
these people it's it's he's he's
becoming like you know Megan and Harry
like they'll it's too much like we get
it but it's all too much haven't you
heard enough I mean didn't we do that in
the Obama Diaries Raymond didn't we
already cover all that I'm pretty sure
all right right there's a Netflix deal
Laura yeah that's right that's right so
as long as we're talking about
um The Fish Out of Water thing Disney's
new live action The Little Mermaid it's
ruling at the box office but what about
the reception it's getting is it all wet
Raymond from some viewers yeah well look
some have complained that this new
adaptation fails to capture their
favorite characters like Sebastian the
secret I mean he doesn't exactly look
lovable and sweet or Scuttle the seagull
the reaction from fans has been so
hostile and voluminous that the Internet
Movie Database site is changing its
rating system they claim quote when
unusual voting activity is detected an
alternative weighing calculation may be
applied in order to preserve the
reliability of our system in other words
The Little Mermaid is not getting the
reaction they'd like so they're changing
the rules isn't that nice wait are they
saying the system is rigged oh no no
can't do that all right maybe the
audience though is on to something
Raymond
[Applause]
yeah the prince has been dropping his he
wants to you know when humans guess all
nights like they're penguins
that's terrifying a bird that's painful
that's
is that supposed to be on okay
well that's the new Lynn Manuel song he
wrote the the rap lyrics to this thing
and they actually took out one of the
classic songs that poisson where the the
chef chases the little crab all over the
kitchen that's been thrown out for this
I think they should have left it as it
was as a cartoon that it becomes to look
like a six seagull on the right that was
a that was a scary Vision that's I'm
gonna have a nightmare thanks Raymond
for that I appreciate it good to see you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else